Ladybugs, sometimes known as Ladybirds and
less commonly Lady Beetles, are a rarity in
the insect world in that they’re one of
the few creepy crawly insects we as a species
don’t actively dislike, due to their habit
of eating the things that destroy our crops.
But just how did this little insect get such
a strange name?
To start, while many members of the Coccinellidae
family are colloquially known as “ladybugs”
in a number of places in the states, technically
speaking they aren’t considered to be true
bugs.
It’s more fitting to instead refer to them
as beetles.
While it’s certainly true that ladybugs
possess several key qualities that bugs share,
to be classified as a true bug, a given insect
must also possess “sucking, beak-like mouth
parts and go from egg to nymph, to adult,
with no larva stage”.
The ladybug neither has the correct mouth
parts nor skips the larval stage, so can’t
fall under this category.
Instead it is, as mentioned previously, a
member of the beetle family, a group of insects
characterised by hard “shell-like” exteriors
that often hides a set of delicate wings.
However, the interesting part here isn’t
the “bug” part of “ladybug” name or
the “bird” part of the other common name-
“ladybird”, with these being somewhat
obvious in their origins.
The less obvious part is why these tiny voracious
beetles have the word “lady” in their
name.
At first glance, there doesn’t appear any
particular reason why this should be the case;
the beetles don’t seem to possess any qualities
associated with the fairer sex.
It turns out, the ladybug isn’t named for
any particular female trait it possesses.
Rather, it is named for a specific lady- the
Virgin Mary.
Why?
This isn’t precisely known.
One of the leading theories is that the name
came about as a result of the ladybug’s
bright red shell, which is not too dissimilar
from the red cloak Mary is often pictured
wearing in biblical paintings.
There’s also an old European legend that
states that farmers many hundreds of years
ago prayed to the Virgin Mary asking for help
to save them from the pests devouring their
crops and in return she sent a swarm of tiny
beetles bearing her trademark coat to eat
them.
In truth, ladybugs are known to dine almost
exclusively on insects we humans consider
pests, like aphids, something old timey farmers
without pesticides or other easy-means of
keeping their crops protected from destructive
creatures were no doubt incredibly thankful
for.
Since back in those days it was common to
thank God for almost any good fortune, it’s
not hard to see how this legend popped up,
and perhaps this gratefulness really did contribute
to the name.
Whatever the case, as it turns out, people
believing the ladybug was a gift from God
(or Mary) is supported by the fact that almost
every European country ended up coming up
with a name for the beetle that linked back
to God or Mary.
For example, in Germany, the word for ladybug
is “Marienkäfer” which translates to
“Mary’s Beetle”; in France, one common
name is “la bete a bon Dieu” which roughly
means “God’s animal” while in Russia
a popular name “Bozhya korovka” which
translates to “God’s little cow”, no
doubt referring to the beetles’ spots which
are not unlike the kind you’d find on certain
cows.
In fact, one of the alternate early names
for the beetle, before “ladybug” or “ladybird”
in English was “ladycow”.
The earliest mention of the word “ladybird”,
referring to the beetle, is noted by the Oxford
English Dictionary to have occurred in 1674
in a dictionary of sorts covering southern
English words.
It was noted in that work that, at that time,
a common slang term for the “little spotted
beetle commonly called the Lady cow, or Lady-bird”
was “bishop”, further demonstrating the
strong association people had with these beetles
and their religion.